all right let's get on with the the
unbelievable failure that is bill burr
already and I'm already talking myself
in the third person so I've even failed
even more I it's I'm six days into a new
decade and I have continued behavior
that I've been trying to get rid of
since at least I don't think in the 90s
I really still argue angry I was I'm in
mm this entire century I have failed
[__] miserably you know I'm like that
franchise that gets a new [__] coach
or a new goddamn draft pick and and and
the whole fan base gets excited and
after one game you like nap it's gonna
be the exact same [__] deal some of
my worst and most embarrassing behavior
as a human being has happened in the
Apple Store I hate that [__] store I
[__] hate that [__] company I hate
Steve Jobs I hate their round building I
[__] hate them and I buy all their
products cuz there's no way out
it's like those poor [__] people who
go to Dubai to get a construction job
and they confiscate if is that you say
confiscate confiscate confiscate your
[__] passport and then you become a
slave I am a slave to that [__]
product I don't know how to [__] get
out of it if I get out of it I literally
cut myself off from three quarters of
[__] humanity I [__] hate those
people
I hate that [__] company don't they
like pay a major fine every year for
their pollution to the environment how
they do this [__] che I don't want to
get going with this [__] [__] so
anyways I bought a [__] laptop now
laptop I bought I I bought an iPad off
the round [__] for aviation purposes
because they got this new software
that's [__] incredible you know that
I just want to make it have it right on
my [__] thighs I'm flying and I know
where the [__] everybody is around me
and it's fights [__] it amazing all
right
so anyways so there's one for Apple and
they created a [__] device but
actually they didn't they ripped off a
device somebody else came up with the
tablet first I don't [__] know so all
I want to do is Roma zoom zoom sorry all
I want to [__] is that song still in my
head all I want to do is go on the
[__] road and not bring my [__]
laptop which weighs nine thousand
[__] pounds even though it does it
compared to the old ones but in my world
it does alright this is just all it's
just just the most so [__]
embarrassing right so I I have this
Olympus LS 100 and what I want to do is
I want to [__] record a podcast and
then upload it to my [__] iPad and
then just get on with my streamlined
life all right so I have the little
umbilical cord attachment you know what
I learned yesterday lightning to USB
attachment off of my [__] laptop that
I got like a year ago so this year I buy
one of the round [__] [__] tablets I
go to plug the lightning to USB [__]
goddamn thing in and it just keeps
spitting it out like a baby not wanting
to eat its food and you know of course
like a the dumb bald freckled content I
am do I do this
during the [__] I don't know I don't
know how many [__] weeks I had to go
do this where I wasn't going to the
airport in two hours I decide I'm gonna
do this the morning
I'm gonna go to the airport in the
afternoon LAX by the way right so it
doesn't fit so what do I do
do I go well I mean I mean that's how
this company operates I do what this was
what I signed up with them they've been
doing this to me no I didn't do that I
flipped out like this was the first time
I are experienced this kunti selfish
greedy [__] behavior
from these [__] ad than that [__]
[__] [__] company right up there
with the cruise ships how they pull into
port and just leave the [__] thing
running could give a [__] about the
future of anybody so it spits it out and
I have a direct moment so my wife cuz
she's a saint she just goes you want to
just go over the apples too and just go
get the attachment you need oh no no no
no no or what happened before that we
called I called up the [__] this this
bootleg Apple [__] place to see if
they haven't and of course I don't know
what it is that I want I'm going like I
got a yeah hey I have I got a I got a I
got a I have a iPad this is me trying to
explain [__] the star Trak [__] from
nowadays and I'm like I need do you have
that attachment where I can plug like a
[__] external DVD you know right into
the decisions like I'm sorry I don't
have something for a TV that just and I
was like just forget I said DVD forget I
said that the thing so I can plug in
like I'm on a podcast and I she said we
don't I don't just can you hang on a
second she came back I knew she had what
I needed I just didn't know what the
word was for it and she just kept saying
we don't have it and I just hung up on
her I hung up on her because I didn't
know what the thing that I use every
twice a [__] week was called so of
course it wasn't my fault it was her
fault and I was saying things like DVD
player to a young person which is like
me saying butter churner try to hook
this butter churner and in my [__]
you know the flat thing it's like it's
like a laptop but it doesn't have a
keyboard but you can get one except you
have to have a password and then you'll
forget what that that thing is and then
you'll just wake up staring at it
knowing that you have all the technology
you need and you have no [__] idea
how to figure out how to get the
password for a [__] keyboard do you
have one of those things so that
conversation ended in failure and then I
just said
[__] it I'm just gonna bring this
[__] thing that me most of my anger
had to do with the fact that I was
leaving my wife and cake for a week so
we end up going down on the [__]
Apple store in my laughs tells me why
don't you bring everything that you need
that you want to plug into this [__]
thing so I brought my tablet I bought my
external DVD probably thinking like hey
man why are you using your external DVD
it's like as I don't know where to go to
watch the movies online I don't know
okay I got some screeners I wanted to
watch that movie 19:17 they gave me a
[__] DVD I have an external DVD
[__] thing I could stick it in I could
watch it on the plane
and enjoy myself right so I go there and
I talked to this poor bastard who works
there right
you know nice as hell I go how are you
sir how you doing he says great I said
listen and I brought the old [__]
thing that worked the old
lightning to [__] USB right which I
learned when I got diagnosed I goes oh
you need a lightning to USB I go oh that
was what is called he says yes hey so he
says that's not a problem and I'm like
holy [__]
I'm gonna walk into this store I met one
of the geniuses he's such a genius he
knows what this [__] freckled dummy
wants so we all walk over to the wall by
the way I brought in everything in one
of those like you know those cloth
things that you bring to the grocery
store so you don't use plastic bags so
they don't end up in the ocean around
some [__] poor fish's head or up the
nose of some turtle whatever the [__]
happens right so I got all my [__] in
there right so the guy goes over and he
goes yeah we have one of those and I'm
like oh my god it's kind of work out
it's finally Bill Byrne and Technology
are finally gonna have a good day right
and guys I know this is all my [__]
fault okay
I mean the pollutant for the environment
thing is on the round cuts but like I I
know that if I just took the [__]
time if I this if this [__] on any level
[__] interest me if I actually just
took the time to say I could do this
you have to understand in my house I
don't know how to use the DVD player
I don't know how to get to Apple TV I
don't know how to do anything I just I
yell upstairs I'm like Nia how do I get
the [__] and she stomps down the [__]
stairs and she just does it for me all
right
she's doing everything when it comes to
technology it's it's she might as well
just be like feeding me like spikes soup
I just I don't know right so my thing is
is once I learn how to do something i
memorize it okay there's no
understanding it's just straight
memorization and then what happens is
some new system comes along or some new
[__] thing and then I have to learn
it all over again and then that's when
it goes off the rails all right I
[__] hate this [__] all right
I bought that [__] Prius okay in 2007
all right October 2007 so a little over
12 years ago guess what it still [__]
works I can still get in it push the
button it still turns on and still does
what the [__] it's supposed to do this
[__]
this Apple [__] doesn't this Apple [__]
works for 18 months okay and then it's
like you're putting out a disco record
in 1982 and wondering why it didn't get
on the charts that's what I [__] hate
you spend three thousand [__] dollars
to these [__] and for something
that's gonna last for 18 [__] months
before it's gonna start slowing down you
know you ever see a killer whales like
going after a [__] whale and they
just chase it until it gets tired and
then they bite its [__] tongue out and
they watch it [__] bleed to death
that's what it's like buying one of
these [__] things the second you get
it those [__] nerds and that round
building are working as fast as humanly
possible to make what the [__] you just
made completely [__] useless
so we go over to the wall in the round
[__] store right and he's yeah we got
that we got that and I'm like oh my god
it's gonna happen it's gonna happen and
then he's looking he's looking and he
starts making a face and I'm like oh no
don't do this to me daddy you know come
on you know it's like I'm a Chargers fan
please please pick the right guy please
pick the right guy in the draft please
don't [__] trade him away once you
pick them please right
and he goes oh I know we have I'm going
come on man you're a huge store I know
you have this I'm trying to put good
vibes out all right
well my entire being is going bill just
pack up your laptop pack up your
external DVD say goodbye to this nice
young man and just walk out of the store
because this [__] never [__] works
out for you and I'm like no don't pack
up because then you're putting it out to
the universe that this isn't gonna work
out all right so for three seconds I was
able to hold my temper while this guy is
now calling the back of the [__]
store to find the lightning to USB
[__] stupid thing that I need for my
[__] goddamn laptop I mean sorry for
my tablet and I don't I don't really
remember what happened next I somehow
just said I said I didn't have a
muttering to myself never [__]
[__] [__] fails I hate this
[__] thing you know people's you know
as they're looking at new tablets are
glancing over the shoulder like why what
is going on with this guy so I start
aggressively putting my my my [__]
iPad in boom threw that in the bag
[__] DVD playing bill put that in the
bag and I must have thrown something
else in the bag I don't know why I
picked the bag up and underneath my bag
unbeknownst to me was my cell phone okay
and the screen is now cracked in three
different [__] places and right as
I'm taking in trying to figure out how
the [__] it was like a magic trick like
how the [__] did my [__]
cellphone screen get cracked like that
correct as I'm taking in that
information because I didn't realize I
was so mad in the moment that I just did
that I just picked the bag up when I was
like why the [__] is the screen all
cracked as I said that the Apple Genius
guy goes oh yeah we have one of those
cords in the back so now I got what I
wanted and I just created a new problem
I set off [__] it's guys cracked my
[__] screen the guys like oh man I go
now I need a new phone right he goes
well we can fix the screen I go how
long's that take it goes there's no
telling today we're really busy I go I
got to be on a plane in two hours he
goes you want to get a new phone it's
like I don't want to get a new [__]
phone and then I'm just sitting there
and then the cord comes out and I'm just
going like yeah I and I literally say to
this poor kid I go you know what I go I
absolutely [__] hate this [__]
company I never have a good experience
when I'm getting mad at him because I
had just waited another three [__]
seconds if I had just [__] waited I
wouldn't have been in this situation
right but that's not how I'm [__]
wired so I [__] actually went in
there they had what I needed I just
didn't have the [__] patience to wait
three [__] seconds and then the
process is a 51 year old man had a
temper tantrum at a mall at 51 it broke
the [__] screen of my cell phone in
three places before this kid went and
got me what the [__] I needed and I'm
[__] flipping out I wasn't yelling I
was just [__] [__]
[__] you guys know you I said
don't do you know yet you guys play this
[__] fine against the [__] if I
was just looking at me and he was so
cool but I'm sorry man
I'm sorry he was the coolest dude ever
there was two other [__] people there
looking over at me whispering so I
[__] walk out with all this
technology in this [__] bag and my
busted cell phone with the cord that I
now need and I come walk it out my
wife's a with my kid and she's going did
they have what you need
I said yes they did and she's looking at
me then why do you have that look on
your face it's like Oh cuz I smashed up
my [__] cell phone and then you know
and then you know I dropped an f-bomb
and then my little kid looks at me she
goes dad dad don't say that don't say
that I go you're right buddy you're
right buddy
and then she starts giving me Dada you
have to be nice to people you can not
she starts giving me a lecture right and
I'm having to walk away from my own
daughter because I'm so [__] mad and
I don't even know who at this point and
I don't want to be upset in front of my
kid you know and I'm at this [__]
mall where they've always play like Tony
Bennett and Sinatra like that's when
they're playing all these [__] songs
is I am [__] whispering cursing under
my breath walking by Santa's house that
they're slowly taking apart in the
Christmas tree that they haven't taken
down yet to get back in the [__] car
and I'm trying to find the humor of it
right so we get back to the house my
car's coming to pick me up in about 45
minutes and I take out my lightning to
USB I plug it in to my tablet it does
not spit it out like a toddler and I'm
thinking like okay at least I have this
I then plug in my Olympus 100 it shows
up nowhere I can't find it so I look for
finder to click on cuz that's what I do
on my laptop it shows up nowhere
I can't find it so now I have to go on
my [__] laptop and look up how the
[__] do you where the [__] is the finder
there's no information meaning there is
no finder on the and and I call up and
Ruth emili´s the nice young man who does
the show and I call him up he goes hello
and I'm like Andrew I [__] how the
[__] do you [__] upload a [__]
[__] [__] mother [__]
[__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
podcast and he's laughing God god bless
him he just starts laughing and he tried
to help me out and it didn't work and I
had to bring my laptop anyways and then
I'm going to the airport with my [__] I
wish I could take a [__] picture of
my [__] there's like three stars with
the spiderweb cracks each of them for
each piece of technology that I threw
back in the bag
one of them's the laptop one of them's
the external DVD and I don't know what
the last [__] thing was maybe one of
them bounced I have no [__] idea so
now I am in Memphis Tennessee with my
laptop and my cracked cell phone and I
have to go to the Apple store today and
I'm going in and my goal is just to walk
in there and just I guess basically just
try to maintain my [__] composure I
cannot I cannot [__] believe I am
this [__] old and this is a problem
that I have been working on since I
probably right I might probably I don't
know 33 or 34 he's when I realized that
I had a [__] problem
and I am like 20 years down the [__]
road almost and I had a
meltdown that I would have [__] had
when I was 33 zero improvement you know
like a [__] franchise that just it
just it's never gonna make the [__]
playoffs they're never gonna do anything
right they just never gonna [__] get
it unreal
I'm [__] real my apologies to that
kid who works in anybody else who heard
me at the [__] Apple store I wasn't
screaming I was just [__] [__]
[__] doing that like what the
[__] what the [__] is wrong with me so
that happened all right and I think if
I'm honest with myself it most of it had
to do now that's not I can't even blame
it on the fact that I was gonna be
missing my family this week on the road
it really wasn't that I would have done
that on a sunny [__] Saturday with I
just hit the [__] lottery I would
have done the same goddamn thing by the
way if one more person sends me a tweet
I hate and going is it just me or does
the guy who coach the coaches the bills
look like Bill burr it's not the joke
it's that joke structure please people
it's 2020 please stop using the prefix
is it just me that's right up there with
I know what you think